ok good morning good evening maxi how
are you good morning hello hello ok
today i will
learn my favorite topic language in
german on this topic i will learn with maxi maxi has a
channel for so learn
german that means german in tokyo but you
will in osaka
yes  exactly maybe you can explain a
bit
about yourself explain why and
how is that the duo is in tokyo or in
pink can and how you interested in
german i
started to learn japanese almost twelve years ago and
then i studied a japan and i
I always met Japanese people during my studies who
learned German and because I
learned Japanese, I just enjoyed teaching
German to Japanese students and yes, that's how I
started and on my YouTube channel
I make videos mostly in Japanese
about learning German or about  German
culture and most of the Japanese who
want to learn German
because of what are the main
motives?  and why you want to learn german
i think a lot of people are interested in
classical music and that's why they
would like to either go to germany
or austria to vienna and
study classical music so
play the piano and then it's
one group the other group that and
there are men who are interested in
german history but there are also
several philosophies and otherwise there is
not a very large group of
japanese people who would just like
to go on vacation to
germany and therefore
want to learn a bit of german for the vacation, i.e.
for  German is very
interesting to me that it's Germany
Austria a bit too
so you can get through
it in Switzerland and there's a lot of history and
a lot of nice people but German
has a lot so the German language
has a lot of criticism and so on
a for me so when i
learn languages also languages with a lot of kom
more complicated grammatical rules for
example the slavic languages then i will
ot focus very much on this this gramm
r dramatic regularly exact
y the same that
me other language almost langu
ge easily in german because i have
have no opportunity to bl
w german on german but o
e question so i  I also have
German a book görgl is solved okay
is read
the saying reader yes read exactly i
mean in german they say the ability in
german for example me i
said that but i talked to myself
so the how do you say the past paris
where on  some will that is with a
let's say on a topic so said
made and advertised on others we
have not read or spoken www
how can you and even if we know what
your child knows you can explain
why and how that is like that
then happens for some example with 1
tl and other example with 1 n
so I always think a lot  e japanese
learn too much grammar and if you learn too much
grammar it becomes
difficult to speak because then you have
all the rules at all so i
think it's more important to hear a lot and
just to find german friends so you
can also on the internet because if you
speaks then it's easier but as a
Japanese I recommend learning the
grammar in Japanese because it
's easier to explain than completely
in German yes and sometimes it's good
when Japanese German teachers
explain grammar because they themselves
have learned German as a foreign language and they
have  but in germany there
are many rules but there are always
exceptions and that means you have to but for
me these explanations
anyway you have to get new so usual
habit how do you say i
forgot my german
for me it doesn't matter i
bring  with with error i forgot a
lot of words but it doesn't
matter but i thought whyu  m is
that
how did you want i said went
succeed money spoken said and i
think most of the time i
fall on walls the the dd the verb well i
say yeah laughed or talked but that
's not because i know these rules
that's  because I haven't heard German for a long time now
, but
I've heard a lot through it. I
was in Germany quite often in the 90s
. I did business there. I read
books  if i do
n't have a chance to speak german
then it's a bit worse but that's
how it is not through explanations it
's just criticism
hearing read speaking and yes not we
through these rules
yes i think that too so the
problem with rules there is  there are always exceptions
and once you start
learning the rules
it becomes more difficult to speak
when you have it in your head you
have it you think about the rain  ln after and
you just have such a blockade
it's just important
to practice speaking and above all to
listen a lot so you can now speak a
lot to German there are audio books
phenomenal excellent herbal also
by that is a language as well as
Russian Greek
it  is not the fall height of japanese
very little good Hörburger in japanese
but also by in swedish russian
very very much very nice very well
done so i read a book
that it is serious so
brain researcher his name is manfred spitzer
and he said and he has  also the
video on youtube in our brains are
not made to
remember details and it is very difficult we
will forget all details but
our brains are very good so
let's say templates or models to make patterns
through these very many details that
we already have  forgotten
will develop new hot paris
in german so yes she has  relationships
will develop and that's what allows us
so or
how do you say enable allows that right
euro allows speaking this language
was we have these these patterns these
models but the details
we will always forget
and learn again and still sick was
forgotten
and  i think that's how it is and i also
think, for example, i speak
panic and i would also like english and
it was very difficult to
speak japanese but afterwards
learning to speak english was much easier because i
already knew one language,
that means the more languages  you learn that it's
easier to remember these
groups
yes yes it's not over but i ca
n't keep the grammatical 1 and that
's really
hard to remember but there's a lot you hear and
then you hear it a bit and
then you use it and I think you're
right when he said so sometimes you got
a bit of interference
okay but that's  t not important because i
think you always have more
self-confidence when i know now
i can learn languages i then i learn
it's a matter of time it will
ake longer to le
rn arabic than i don't know itali
n but he doesn't even know how to do it
and  my brain also has the
ability to learn languages has impro
ed by learning another langu
ge that's always a plus exactly you now y
u can I certa
nly can't maybe yes exactly that's the way i
is and t
at's why I think the people in europ
they live if you live in
germany or france danone
belgium
that's not a few hundred
kilometers away you have another language
that's not the case in japan
and also not abroad or in the usa and
that's why many europeans
they have it quite easily yes
questions to learn and i think a lot of
japanese people don't always ask does it mean
to learn german because i
can't even speak english ric  need to speak
but i think if you learn an
additional language then it will
also be easy, for example,
to learn english afterwards too, that's for
sure, because because, for
example, a japanese in germany
that we it will be difficult for a lot of
work for that for that  brain
afterwards english will be easier because it will be
if you do for example
if so difficult
then the easy one will be
much easier so that on and there is
so if you learn more language for
example german because there are
connections between german and
english also between english and
french and then when you
learn another language you learn to think in a different way
and you learn
some estimators that are perhaps
more important
in german than in english or
dom and that helps that improves that's a
development on your ability
to learn languages
that's exactly why yes and i think
a japanese too
we all live in the same who is allowed in
learn several languages japanese germa
swedish i don't know arabi
yes ok so don't try too much
eight or to do a firm on gramm
r yes that was also yes yes that
s that's really ok good thank you very much
hose
were for me and for germa
I need to tell more about
what's included